♪ ♪
>> Lawrence: WELCOME BACK.
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID HE
WOULD PULL U.S. TROOPS FROM
AFGHANISTAN BY MAY 1ST, BUT
JOE BIDEN'S TAKEN HIS TIME AND
ANNOUNCING TODAY THAT HE WILL
PULL TROOPS BY THE 20TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ATTACKS ON
SEPTEMBER THE 11TH.
JOINING ME NOW IS
GENERAL JACK KEANE, FOX NEWS
SENIOR STRATEGIC ANALYST.
GENERAL, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING WITH ME TONIGHT.
>> GREAT TO BE HERE, LAWRENCE.
>> Lawrence: GENERAL,
OBVIOUSLY, I AM EXCITED ABOUT
THIS, BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN FAR
TOO LONG.
BUT I WANT TO START BY FIRST
TALKING ABOUT WHERE HE IS MAKING
THE ANNOUNCEMENT, IN ARLINGTON
CEMETERY.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THE
PLACE WHERE HE IS MAKING THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT?
AND THE ANNOUNCEMENT ITSELF, OF
OUR TROOPS FINALLY COMING HOME?
>> WELL, I DON'T HAVE ANY VIEW
ON WHERE HE IS MAKING THE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
PUBLIC POLICY IS HIS CHOICE AND
WHERE HE CHOOSES TO DO IT.
I FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ANNOUNCING
A 1 MAY WITHDRAW, ALTHOUGH HE
DID HAVE IN MIND THERE WOULD BE
CERTAIN CONDITIONS BEFORE THE
UNITED STATES WOULD WITHDRAW,
AND THAT WOULD BE, HOPEFULLY WE
WOULD HAVE A PEACE AGREEMENT
NEGOTIATED BETWEEN THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT AND THE TALIBAN.
AND ALSO, A CEASE-FIRE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT.
WE HAVE STALEMATED NEGOTIATIONS.
SECONDLY, THE TALIBAN HAS
INCREASED THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE
IN THE COUNTRY ITSELF, SO THE
TALIBAN SEES THERE IS POLITICAL
WEAKNESS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES, IN TERMS OF A
RESOLVE TO STAY, THEY HAVE BEEN
OBVIOUSLY TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THAT SITUATION.
I THINK THIS DECISION IS
MISGUIDED BECAUSE IT'S RECKLESS
AND IT'S ALSO SHAMEFUL.
IT'S SHAMEFUL BECAUSE WE ARE
ABANDONING THE AFGHAN
GOVERNMENT.
IN MY MIND, IF THEY SURRENDER TO
THE TALIBAN.
IT'S RECKLESS, BECAUSE WHY ARE
WE STILL THERE?
WHAT ARE WE REALLY DOING THERE?
FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE NOT
FIGHTING A CONVENTIONAL WAR, AS
PEOPLE ARE ASCERTAINING WE ARE.
WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT SINCE 2014,
WHEN WE PULLED ALL THE COMBAT
TROOPS OUT.
WHAT ARE THESE FEW THOUSAND
TROOPS DOING THERE?
THEY ARE IN AFGHANISTAN FOR THE
SAME REASON THAT WE HAVE TROOPS
IN FOUR OTHER PLACES WHERE WE
BELIEVE RADICAL ISLAM WILL DO
HARM TO US.
THERE'S 40 OR 50 MOVEMENTS OF
RADICAL ISLAMISTS AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE ARE NOT CHASING ANY OF THOSE.
BUT MULTIPLE PRESIDENTS HAVE
SAID WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN SYRIA,
WITH ISIS REEMERGING, LET'S MAKE
CERTAIN THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN.
AND WE HAVE A FEW HUNDRED TROOPS
THERE.
WE HAVE TROOPS IN IRAQ FOR THE
SAME REASON, AND THAT IS A
COUPLE THOUSAND.
IT'S CLASSIFIED, THE NUMBER THAT
IS TARGETING THE AL QAEDA IN
YEMEN, BUT THEY HAVE ASPIRATIONS
ALSO TO ATTACK AMERICA.
WE HAVE 700 OR 800 TROOPS IN
EASTERN AFRICA, BECAUSE THAT
RADICAL ISLAMIC ORGANIZATION,
AL-SHABAAB, HAS ASPIRATIONS TO
ATTACK AMERICA.
THAT IS IT.
AND THE 3,000 TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN ARE THERE FOR THE
VERY SAME REASON.
THE POTENTIAL RISE OF AL QAEDA,
WHICH WAS THE PLACE WHERE THEY
ATTACKED US FROM 9/11, AND MAKE
CERTAIN THAT BASIS, WHICH HAS
GROWN IN THE COUNTRY, DOES NOT
DO THAT.
MOST OF US LOOK AT THAT AND SAY,
"MY, THAT IS A MODEST INVESTMENT
TO GET SUCH A POSITIVE GAIN OUT
OF THAT."
AN INSURANCE POLICY BE
UNITED STATES IS NOT GOING TO BE
ATTACKED AGAIN.
>> Lawrence: YOU KNOW,
GENERAL, I HAVE IMMENSE RESPECT
FOR YOU WHEN YOU ARE AN EXPERT
ON THIS ISSUE, BUT THE MAJORITY
OF THE COUNTRY DOESN'T FEEL THAT
WAY, AND MANY ASK A QUESTION
BECAUSE THERE IS ALWAYS A
CHANCE OF A VACUUM OPENING, AND
TERRORISTS COMING BACK AND
FORMING SOME OTHER GROUP.
WHEN WILL THEY EVER LEAVE?
>> WELL, THE TERRORISTS HAVEN'T
LEFT THE BATTLEFIELD, LAWRENCE.
WE DON'T KEEP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE INFORMED AND ADVISED, IS
WHAT'S GOING ON.
NONE OF OUR PRESIDENTS HAVE EVER
DONE A VERY GOOD JOB OF DOING
THAT.
AND THE FACTS ARE, THEY ARE
STILL OUT THERE.
AND AS I SAID, I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE DONE AND WHAT WE HAVE
MATURED AND EVOLVED TO IS A VERY
SPECIFIC AND FOCUSED THREAT ON
ONLY THOSE GROUPS THAT HAVE
ASPIRATIONS TO HURT AMERICA.
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND IT IS A MODEST INVOLVEMENT
IN DOING THAT, AND IT'S A
COMPLETE DISTORTION, TALKING
ABOUT THIS MAJOR WAR THAT WE ARE
INVOLVED IN AFGHANISTAN IS JUST
NOT THE CASE.
>> Lawrence: SO, GENERAL, AND
I HAVE TO GO, BUT IF I COULD GET
A QUICK RESPONSE TO YOU.
IS IT NO LONGER A STRATEGY OF
THE UNITED STATES TO CHANGE
HEARTS AND MINDS THERE?
IS THAT NO LONGER THERE?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHEN WE EVER HAD
THAT STRATEGY.
WE WENT THERE TO KILL THE
TALIBAN, WHO WOULD NOT GIVE UP
THE AL QAEDA, WHICH WE DID
SUMMARILY, AND DEPOSED THAT
REGIME, AND THEN RUN THE
AL QAEDA INTO THEIR HOLES AND
KILL AS MANY OF THEM AS WE CAN,
AND WE DID THAT.
WHAT WE DIDN'T DO IS WE GOT
DEFLECTED BY THE WAR IN IRAQ AND
WE DID NOT FOLLOW THE AL QAEDA
ACROSS THE BORDER INTO PAKISTAN
AND FINISH THE JOB IS WHAT WE
SHOULD'VE DONE.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU.
>> SO THERE'S OTHER POLICIES
THAT GOT IN THE WAY.
>> Lawrence: THANK YOU S